hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom and a lot of people have been
asking me lately what my five minute
beauty routine is to get the way that I
look in the one mom offices so I figured
I should show you because it's very very
easy and anybody can do it so let's get
started the first thing you're going to
want to do is pour yourself a tall glass
of wine if you're gonna be going through
the effort of doing your makeup next
tinted moisturizer those are two words
that change in my life it is really
amazing kind of like moisturizing cream
that makes your skin look like it has
all of its nutrients and that you see
the sunlight and like the light of day
regularly if you're gonna get a line
right here if you don't rub it down into
your neck next ever since I had kids all
of a sudden my skin's like hey puberty
let's bring these back you're gonna want
to get some concealer and I just like
take that on I don't even bother with
like blending I'm just like hey put a
patch on each and then figure the rest
out next winged eyeliner longbow mount
I'm for that
forget it we go stream to mascara
because that's where it's at that's what
that really matters you have your
mascara you look put together I invest
in a volumizing mascara you want to make
sure to get your bottom lashes because
that's gonna open your eyes up but the
problem I face a lot of the time with
the bottom lashes is all start putting
it on and then the mascara gets all over
my lower lid here's a quick awesome
trick just take a pinky blend it into
your dark circles and this is gonna just
blend right in you're not even gonna
notice that it's there can you even tell
boom I don't let's drop my wine no next
this is typically where you'd put on
some blush for a little bit of color but
I lost my blush about three months ago
just never bought anymore so I'm just
not doing it anymore you're gonna go
into your contour I bought this
contouring kit that's a concealer kit it
comes with this light light light white
concealer and this is key you're gonna
take some of this and I mean don't be
shy with this you're gonna rub it on the
back of your hand then you're gonna take
a dark brown eyeshadow any shade of dark
brown you're gonna dust this all over
the white contouring concealer you want
to saturate this
take this there's gonna gently wipe it
across your forehead everyone knows what
I'm talking about where you're like
doing something you get something Brown
on your hand and you wipe your forehead
and you don't realize until a few hours
later that's what we're going for here
this contouring concealer palette is
actually good for a lot of different
things any other thing I like to use it
for is this white concealer I'm just
gonna rub a little bit in between my
fingers and get it in my hair and that's
kind of like a white mystery stain just
like I don't know if it's puke I don't
know if it's butt cream I don't know
what it is but it's in there and that's
like so mom with me it looks great the
last piece of makeup you're really gonna
want is a decent red lipstick and my mom
has told me this since I was literally
born it doesn't matter how you look long
as you have a good red lipstick so we're
gonna get on some red lipstick oh man if
you get a little residue brown on your
face that's like not a big deal either
you just that's for later so that's it
it's very simple if you have any other
mom makeup tips leave it in the comments
because I personally don't see how you
can get any better than this I'm Hannah
your friendly neighborhood wine mom till
next time
[Music]